the same philosophy here that that I was
like a pro-trump supporter right I
walked through the airports I had I have
another YouTube it's still up there but
I'm not gonna say what it is but it went
viral so I had a tank top that said
blacks for trumps right blacks blacks
for Trump and I went through LAX San
Francisco airport with my Mexican
girlfriend right it went viral right and
it was more of a political YouTube and I
found that in the black community we
were still absorbed with the whole we
were in Doctrine in the whole notion
that Democrats were there to help so I
have a couple philosophies it's like hey
I don't need help I never needed a
handout I went to schools that said I
wasn't black enough I went to schools
that said I wasn't white enough I mean
I'm stuck in the middle I had to deal
with both sides right and so the whole
point was growing up I grew up liberal
then I owned businesses and I became a
conservative I voted right I don't say
I'm a conservative person but I vote
right does that make sense yeah but I
say I'm alt-right alt right okay there
you go